[Musique]
salut a tous ravis de vous retrouver ici
à strasbourg pour 30 minutes de
décryptage de l'actualité européenne
dans cette émission direction la
belgique le 14 mars c'est le jour de
l'equal pay day c'est le jour où les
femmes finissent leur année salariale et
atteignent la même rémunération que les
hommes qui gagnent en moyenne 20% de
plus depuis des années des associations
tentent de faire évoluer les pratiques
reportages et débats
à suivre mais d'abord l'actualité
glyphosate pesticides lactalis traité de
libre-échange gaspillage alimentaire
depuis toujours les controverses les
polémiques ne manquent pas sur la scène
européenne au sujet de la sécurité
alimentaire et pour répondre à ces
questions
le commissaire vie tennis andre united
est notre invité rencontre vite et
lisandro gates bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci de
l'invitation
vous êtes commissaire européen la
sécurité alimentaire ancien ministre de
la santé en lituanie alors on s'en
souvient toussaint l'union européenne
s'étaient écharpés il ya encore quelques
mois sur la question du glyphosate vous
avez réautoriser au niveau européen le
glyphosate donc la substance pour cinq
ans en france le président de la
république et nicolas hulot propose une
interdiction d'ici à trois ans est ce
que vous y croyez
au même stade à eaunes tous les états
membres ont leurs propres listes de
pesticides enregistrés et ils sont
également obligés d'introduire des plans
nationaux d'utilisation des pesticides
pour avoir un contrôle des usages et une
gestion des sols au niveau national
management honda g ayew j toutes les
exploitations utilisent des pesticides
les fermes biologiques utilise du
coupeur par exemple tous les usages de
pesticides ou des mélanges de plusieurs
pesticides autorisés dans les sols sont
de la responsabilité des états membres
ils ont tout à fait le droit de faire ce
qu'on appelle des up out d'interdire
leur usage s'ils le souhaitent
ce qui signifie que la france a
aujourd'hui le droit de décider de sa
politique en matière de pesticides
toujours en france il ya quelques
semaines on a été frappé par le scandale
de producteurs de lait lactalis on a
découvert donc des salmonelles dans les
productions de lait une alerte a été
lancée et on a vu qu'il y avait eu quand
même quelques soucis pour le producteur
a retiré donc ces produits des
rayonnages
est ce que il n'ya pas un problème là
aussi de traçabilité est ce que l'union
européenne ne devrait pas mettre en
place une forme de contrôle indépendant
de ces industriels quand on voit à quel
point la sécurité alimentaire est
menacée les autorités françaises ont
fait leur travail elles ont annoncé
immédiatement l'activation des
mécanismes d' alerte
les pays voisins ont été avertis et la
situation est absolument sous contrôle
aujourd'hui oui j'entends monsieur le
commissaire mais ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas justement pour garantir cette
sécurité alimentaire mettre en place un
contrôle indépendant de ces industriels
et non pas une forme d'autocontrôle
comme on le voit aujourd'hui
vous savez lorsque vous parlez d'une soi
disant indépendance les gens aiment
beaucoup ce terme d'indépendance
mais de quoi parle-t-on je ne sais pas
de quoi on parle
en substance il faut définir ce que
signifie indépendance dans l'union
européenne
nous avons quatre niveaux de contrôle et
de responsabilité
quatre niveaux aulas va opérer premier
niveau
les opérateurs sont obligés légalement
de contrôler leur production et ils
connaissent les conséquences d'un
manquement et le second niveau et le
niveau de contrôle administratif
régional ou local
cela dépend des institutions de chaque
état membre
lavrov ensuite le troisième niveau et
celui de l'état
le niveau national et enfin le quatrième
celui de l'union européenne
un système de contrôle officiel
harmoniser et qui couvrent tous les
secteurs
vous avez quatre différents systèmes de
contrôle
l'indépendant vous n'avez aucune chance
vous ne pouvez pas avoir d' influence
sur tous ces niveaux investigate dont le
cas lactalis l'enquêté est en cours
il incombe aux autorités nationales
d'investiguer en coopération avec ses
différents niveaux de contrôle alors
l'union européenne multiplie les
négociations d'accords de libre échange
on pense notamment celui sur le mercosur
en ce moment donc en amérique latine
comment garantir là aussi la sécurité
alimentaire quand on sait que le brésil
notamment a eu des soucis à de viande
avariée et que l'union européenne a
arrêté les importations comment garantir
la traçabilité de ces produits
d'amérique latine francophone round like
what are you knew d'abord je veux vous
dire que les normes de sécurité
alimentaire en europe sont parmi les
meilleurs dans le monde
nous n'avons pas le droit d'envoyer ou
d'importer des biens des produits qui ne
respectent pas nos normes de sécurité
alimentaire
mais avez-vous véritablement confiance
dans la capacité de pays comme le brésil
qui ont déjà failli à assurer cette
sécurité alimentaire et à faire cette
traçabilité cause nous parlons
aujourd'hui du boeuf tous les
producteurs de boeuf établi au brésil
n'exporte pas en europe seuls 300 le
peuvent seulement ceux qui ont été
contrôlés audités et qui ont aujourd'hui
un certificat qui le leur permet ce sont
les seuls qui ont le droit d'exporter
vers l'union européenne et vers la
france nous n'avons pas autorisée par
exemple l'importation de viande de porc
car nous avons détecté qu'il utilisait
des hormones ce fut stoppée aucune
chance etc les stades clés à ce message
mais non nous faisons passer un message
clair aujourd'hui il n'est pas possible
de diminuer nos standards de sécurité
alimentaire car c'est ce qui nous permet
aussi d'exporter à l'étranger aogo de
sabra
je ne comprends pas pourquoi les gens
dissémine ce type d'information nous
avons des problèmes concrets dans
l'union européenne
nous avons eu la crise de la vache folle
des salmonelles des dioxines salmona là
ce type de crise arrive aussi au brésil
en chine
partout c'est la vie mais nous le
contrôlons dernière question alors on
sait qu'une pétition a été déposée sur
votre bureau concernant le gaspillage
alimentaire
comment assurer que une directive soit
proposée avant le renouvellement en mai
2010 neuf du parlement européen et de la
commission
my life j'ai une réponse simple cette
pétition doit être enregistrée par
l'union européenne les initiateurs ont
aujourd'hui stopper leurs actions la
pétition est prête mais elle n'a pas été
enregistré ni présenter devant la
commission afin qu'elles puissent
aboutir à des propositions concrètes ni
où cela est nécessaire pour mettre en
route les procédures légales qui se
termine par une directive
mais avant nous devons mettre en place
des évaluations d'impact des dialogue
avec la société civile des échanges avec
les directions générales concernés cela
ne se fera pas en un mois
mais surtout les initiateurs doivent la
faire enregistrer au plus vite au jeu
acciona merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
21 merci voilà pour cette rencontre
enregistré il y a quelques jours alors
connaissez-vous l'equal pay day c'est le
jour de l'année qu'il faut atteindre
pour les femmes pour obtenir le même
salaire que les hommes en france ce sera
le 26 mars et en belgique c'est le 14
mars des associations tentent de changer
les pratiques c'est un reportage de
jérôme rhabiller
[Musique]
je la vois famille
c'est un clip pour éveiller les
consciences
comme chaque année l'association belge a
eu quand diffuse un spot publicitaire
pour dénoncer l'inégalité hommes femmes
en matière salariale
ici un jeune homme épouse une femme âgée
mais rapidement le conte de fée vire au
drame et le mari décide de commettre
l'irréparable
[Musique]
au moment du passage chez le notaire
c'est la déception une manière décalée
d'évoquer des retraites bien plus faible
chez les femmes conséquence logique des
différences de salaires sa diffusion est
prévue pour l'equal pay day jour qui
correspond chaque année à la date
jusqu'à laquelle les femmes devraient
travailler en plus pour toucher autant
que les hommes
cette année en belgique c'est le 14 mars
soit 20 % d'écart salarial depuis 13 ans
maintenant
et quand tu as choisi ce mode de
communication pour sensibiliser au sujet
ce problème là n'a pas très grande
donc pour vraiment créer un effet choc
pour vraiment dire aux gens résoudre
c'est bien de faire bouger les choses
donc de choquer minimum on reste
toujours positif on n'entre jamais dans
la négativité de rester voilà d'avoir
une touche légère dont accompagne aussi
le problème derrière est assez grave par
contre on belgique l'écart salarial est
donc de 20 % mais seulement 2 6% si l'on
prend les salaires at-on de travail égal
la faute notamment un temps partiel
souvent subie chez les femmes mais des
réseaux se développe pour renforcer leur
place dans les entreprises chez job
c'est même devenu une raison d'être ici
on dispense des formations
on accompagne des entreprises et on
organise des forums pour partager les
bonnes pratiques
on va faire un petit point de l'état la
désinscription du forum parce que c'est
dans une semaine pour sa fondatrice
c'est un investissement de tous les
acteurs qui doit inciter aux bonnes
pratiques
c'est comme une voiture sur une pente si
on n'a pas tout le temps le pied sur
l'accélérateur
la voiture elle va reculer
automatiquement donc je pense que c'est
vraiment une attention des politiques
une attention de la société civile qui
met la pression sur les entreprises qui
leur font savoir que c'est devenu
totalement intolérable pour le public
pour les citoyens de savoir qu'une femme
qui travaille de la même façon qu'un
homme qui a les mêmes qualifications
n'est pas payée de la même façon
[Musique]
des entreprises qui s'engagent il y en a
en belgique chez atlan société
spécialisée dans le financement de
location de voitures longue durée le
general manager a même été désigné
ambassadeur pour l'égalité
professionnelle grâce à des mesures très
simples à mettre en place pour que on a
possibilité de chercher les enfants ou
les déposer à l'école quand il ya une
enfant malade y a pas d'explication à
d'années on peut on peut rester à la
maison et ont donc qu'il ya plein de
petits règles qu'on a mis en place pour
faciliter la balance vie privée vie
professionnelle
une nouvelle culture d'entreprise qui
lui sert aussi à se démarquer face à des
concurrents et donc à attirer des
talents
cette image de société un peu une vente
dans sa réflexion mais aussi qui cherche
vraiment à réinventer la manière de
travailler nous aident à recruter des
profils dans lequel on pouvait que rêver
avant et c'est réussi
[Musique]
des pratiques qui commence à séduire de
plus en plus d'entreprises
même si l'écart salarial entre femmes et
hommes se réduit trop lentement
d'où l'urgence pour certains politiques
de prendre de nouvelles mesures plus
coercitives notamment au niveau européen
il ya une directive qui est sur la table
du conseil donc des états membres depuis
cinq ans et qui est la directive des
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration qui irait vers une
représentation de femmes dans les
conseils d'administration aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment bloquant et je trouve
qu'on doit faire des campagnes beaucoup
plus fort que personne ne sait que cette
initiative est bloqué par les états
membres
en france une loi oblige les plus
grandes entreprises à avoir au moins 40
% de membres femmes dans leur conseil
d'administration
une mesure que l'europe pourrait
généraliser et étendre à toutes les
entreprises quelle que soit leur taille
[Musique]
alors comment atteindre la parité
l'égalité salariale pour en débattre
j'ai le plaisir de recevoir sylvie
guillaume bonjour vous êtes vice
présidente du parlement européen membre
du groupe socialiste et démocrate et
vous êtes à la commission libertés
civiles justice et affaires intérieures
vous êtes très engagé sur ces questions
en face de vous claude rolin bonjour et
bienvenue vous êtes député belge membre
du groupe ppe et membre de la commission
emploi et affaires sociales vous êtes
par ailleurs ancien syndicaliste
vous avez été secrétaire général de la
confédération des syndicats chrétiens
alors nous sommes en 2018 j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait ce débat
dix fois qu'est ce qu'on attend pour
véritablement faire en sorte que cette
égalité salariale se mettent en oeuvre
cette vidéo vous avez raison de dire
qu'on a l'impression de refaire toujours
le même débat
j'ai vérifié le traité de rome parle
déjà d'égalité de rémunération ok donc
il ya 70 ans
résultat des courses on a passé
quasiment une vie humaine
et puis il ya eu des évolutions
évidemment puisque les choses ont changé
en termes d'égalité salariale il ya
d'ailleurs des pays dans l'union
européenne qui sont assez exemplaire
quelquefois on a des clichés par exemple
sur l'italie mais en italie
on a tous une différenciation de niveau
de rémunération entre les hommes et les
femmes qui est assez faible donc à bas
les clichés au moins sûr sur certains
sujets mais c'est vrai qu'il sait assez
peu homogène certains pays ont beaucoup
progressé d'autres malheureusement ont
un peu régressé je pense qu'il ya une
action qui a mené au plan des états
membres on a bien vu et maria reina a
raison de le dire il ya des talents qui
bloquent un certain nombre de directives
européennes qui sont positives sur
l'égalité c'est aussi une question de
mentalité aussi d'éducation
d'information sur les jeunes filles sur
les métiers et sur allag leur capacité à
acquérir des qualifications ça c'est
curieux d'ailleurs puisqu'il ya beaucoup
de jeunes femmes
je crois que le ca doit être valable de
dents dans l'union européenne dans son
ensemble mais les femmes dans les
des études supérieures sont plus
nombreuses que les hommes ne se
retrouvent pas évidemment et notamment
pas à la tête de certaines entreprises
dont qui a ordonné un décrochage qui se
fait qu'il n'est pas seulement lié je le
précise à la maternité claude rolin est
ce qu'il faudrait sanctionner des
entreprises et faire honte entre
guillemets publier les noms de celles
qui ne sont pas très participative
coopératif sur ces questions de légalité
ce ne serait pas forcément de tort de le
faire mais je pense qu'au niveau de
l'entreprise est un enjeu essentiel
c'est un enjeu de concertation sociale
et je prends un exemple que je connais
dans mon pays 1 la question pourquoi on
l'attend depuis autant de temps avant
d'avoir l'égalité salariale
c'est peut-être parce que trop on s'est
contenté d'avoir des législations par
exemple la lustration belge défini
depuis très longtemps on s'est compris
au moins directive européenne qui le
disent
il ne peut pas y avoir d'inégalité
salariale en france la loi de 1972 à
travail égal salaire égal sauf que ceci
ne permet pas l'égalité salariale
pourquoi parce que c'est tout à fait
faciale effectivement quelqu'un qui
ressortissent heures dans un magasin
qu'ils soient hommes ou femmes
il va gagner la même chose à la
différence près que ce sont surtout des
femmes qui sont dans les rayons et des
hommes qui sont aux postes de direction
en europe donc on voit le delta qui se
fait alors quand je dis que la
concertation sociale peut jouer un rôle
important c'est qu'à partir du moment et
nous l'avons en belgique ou non nous
avons négocié des conventions
collectives de travail qui oblige les
entreprises à des moments bien
particulier de travailler sur cette
question d'égalité des chances et un des
moments particuliers c'est ce qu'on
appelle la classification des fonctions
ce sont des enjeux de négociation dans
l'entreprise pour savoir vettel
fonctions on la définit avec tel est l
élément est bien aujourd'hui par une
convention collective
interprofessionnelle
les entreprises et les secteurs sont
obligés d'avoir un regard sur
l'incidence en termes d'égalité
salariale qu'on s'éclate ification de
fonction c'est quelque chose d'important
j'entends la concertation mais ce qu'il
faut pas un moment aller plus loin pour
éviter d'avoir encore ce débat dans dix
ans mais je pense que quand on impose la
concertation et qu'on inclut à l'intérêt
de la concertation sociale
ce type d'élément ça progresse
maintenant il faut être clair que c'est
pas le seul élément qui peut permettre
de progresser
pour moi c'est une question qui est
totalement transversale
ils doivent se situer dans l'ensemble
des politiques qui touche effectivement
à la réalité salariale
cette question doit se poser il faut
jouer effectivement sur toute faute
toutes les mesures ce que dit claude
rolin sur la question des pratiques et
c'est très important et la manière dont
on peut éventuellement échanger sur ces
pratiques
ça c'est fondamental dans l'union mais
voyez par exemple quand on parle de
transparence
je sais qu'il ya des démarches qui sont
faites par exemple en allemagne sur la
transparence sur les salaires
si ça demeure quelque chose d'individuel
en gros dit autrement si une femme qui
s'estime lésée ou avec une différence
salariale à ça en sa défaveur évidemment
demande une transparence
si elle le fait de façon individuelle
c'est vrai que ça reste une démarche qui
n'est pas suffisamment puissante donc
peut-être on peut aussi renverser la
charge de la preuve est considéré que ça
n'est pas la personne qui est lésé de
faire la démonstration qu'elle a tort
mais c'est plutôt à l'entreprise est ce
que c'est ce qu'a fait l'islande en
place typiquement depuis le début de
cette année c'est ça qu'on doit publier
en fait les salaires et que du coup tout
le monde potentiellement peut avoir
accès à ce que gagne son voisin et sur
des titres du coup ça permet
effectivement de renverser la charge de
la preuve est d'agir effective sur sur
la question de la transparence la
visibilité de ces différences
et je crois que c'est aussi un moyen
d'agir on parlait du temps partiel subi
contre 1 on voit par exemple que ça joue
beaucoup dans les écarts salariaux
l'écart salarial en belgique il est de
l'ordre de 6 25% si on prend le temps
plein de 9% en france et dès qu'on
intègre le temps partiel souvent
contraints on passe à 20 % d'écart
salariés en belgique 25 % en france
comment on fait en sorte claude rolin de
sortir de cette de ce fonctionnement je
pense qu'il ya d'abord eu d'éléments en
termes de choix d'orientation
professionnelle certains métiers
demandent plus et temps partiel que
d'autres et donc là il ya en termes
d'orientation
il ya des politiques à voix qui sont
notamment des politiques au départ des
politiques scolaires y compris et un
deuxième élément c'est que quand des
gens qu'ils soient hommes ou femmes mais
c'est plus généralement des femmes
choisissent ou son contraire du temps
partiel ce qu'ils aient une possibilité
une priorité pour avoir un emploi à
temps plein s'il le désire ça peut
paraître quelque chose
d'importants un élément qu'on oublie
souvent en matière de temps partiel vous
avez cité les chiffres pour la belgique
ça crée une inégalité sur les salaires
mais ça crée une inégalité encore plus
terrible sur les éléments qui sont liées
à la sécurité sociale
je pense que tu l'as nancy lorraine sur
les retraites c'est quelque chose qui
est désastreux
aujourd'hui quand on voit dans l'est
surtout dans les familles monoparentales
avec des des dames qui sont en dessous
du niveau de pauvreté
pas parce que les règles de pension ne
leur permettrait pas d'avoir un salaire
suffisant mais tout simplement parce
qu'on calculent leur pension sur le
nombre d'années qu'elles ont pu
travailler et sur la fraction horaires
où elles ont travaillé ce qui pose pour
moi ce qui devrait pas un qui devrait
nous imposer d'avoir des systèmes qu'ils
fassent en sorte que les périodes qui
sont deux noms travailler dans le cadre
de deux temps partiel contraint puisse
avoir une certaine assimilation en
termes de droit de la sécurité une forme
de bonification tout à fait mais je
pense également vous l'avez signalé
moi je suis très sensible à la nature
des métiers de services notamment dans
lesquels les femmes sont évidemment sur
se représenter je pense qu'il faut
également
ça dépasse le débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui mais il faut également agir
sur la nature de ces emplois sur leur
rémunération et sur les contraintes que
cela représente pour ces femmes
par ailleurs ce sont des métiers
absolument indispensable oui c'est
qu'ils ont amené à développer notamment
tendent à se développer donc qui devront
se structurer et ne plus être cette
espèce de tiers travail tel qu'il est
quelquefois exprimé en ce moment alors
je m'entendais marié arena dans le
reportage qui évoquait cette proposition
de directive qui est sur la table du
conseil pour la parité dans les conseils
d'administration alors bon soyons clairs
on est aussi dans le symbole sur ces
questions de parité
pourquoi ça bloque encore en 2018 que
dans là parce que je pense pour deux
raisons une raison culturelle et qu'on
considère qu'il n'y a pas à légiférer
dans ce type de matière c'est là quelque
part c'est la nature
je pense qu'il ya aussi une raison en
termes de de volonté de laisser
l'entreprise faire les choses ce que
l'entreprise fait et bien par essence
alors que moi j'ai rien contre les
entreprises est faux
m aux entreprises de se développer mais
je pense qu'il faut aussi que les
entreprises se situent dans des cadres
qui sont bien précis et je pense que les
mois je suis pas un partisan des quotas
en terme théorique mais quand y'a pas
moyen de faire évoluer les situations
mais l'obligation paraît pas et la
meilleure des choses je pense qu'il faut
devoir passer par là pour arriver à
avancer puisqu'on a fait malheureusement
la démonstration que sont certains
n'avançait pas voyez le parallélisme
qu'on peut faire avec une autre un autre
domaine que la question des violences et
les blocages qu'on peut voir sur
l'adhésion ou la ratification de la
convention d'istanbul qui est le seul
instrument international contraignant
sur la lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes
là encore onze pays dans l'union
européenne qui refusent par principe je
donne cette ratification alors pour les
motifs que vous avez indiquée
culturellement on veut pas rentrer là
dedans ça n'existe pas ou c'est une
façon de faire chez nous qui est acquis
et qui est adoptée aux communes ou bien
on n'accepte pas que l'union aucune
institution internationale viennent nous
dire ce qu'il faut faire
donc on voit les résistances qui existe
parallèlement des formes on exactement
dans le même domaine vis-à-vis de
l'égalité salariale au regard l'autre
conservatisme aussi le la question du
temps partiel ou du congé parental pour
les hommes c'est un petit peu une
question taboue il y avait aussi une
législation qui était potentiellement en
cours d'imagination
claude rolin mais on a encore deux au
moins deux éléments qui sont sur la
table il ya le socle social qui doit
être traduit parce qu'on a là une série
d'intention je trouve une déclaration
d'intention mais c'est important c'est
plus que symbolique c'est le socle
européen des droits sociaux est
effectivement un paquet qui est produite
devrait nous permettre d'avancer à
condition de le traduire dans des faits
concrets et que les états membres
prennent leurs responsabilités aussi en
la matière il ya toute la question aussi
qu'ils doivent être prises en compte de
comment on améliore l'équilibré dans la
gestion la prise en compte de tout ce
qui sont les éléments de gestion
familiale un dock si on laisse
simplement un droit au congé de
paternité qu'on peut prendre qu on ne
peut pas prendre
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ces cas là
il se passe que ce sont les femmes qui
sont en dehors du travail la majorité en
tous les cas des femmes et pas les
hommes donc on a pas d' équilibre
il faut forcer un meilleur équilibre et
en forçant ce meilleur équilibre on va
permettre aux gens et quand même je
pense
l'essence même de la de la démarche
politique aujourd'hui mieux
bah écoutez façon on va se retrouver
l'année prochaine pour débattre de cette
question je ne suis pas convaincu qu'on
puisse arriver à trouver une solution
d'ici 2019 alors c'est l'heure du
checkpoint le checkpoint cette semaine
s'est intéressé à la libéralisation du
rail en france et aux réformes annoncées
autour de la sncf
le checkpoint cette semaine est préparée
par kevin 0 et s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
le gouvernement français compte réformer
en profondeur la sncf
ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde et
certains annoncent même une prochaine
bataille du rail dont le train des
propositions il ya la libéralisation des
chemins de fer et le premier ministre
edouard philippe de déclarer partout où
elle a lieu chez nos voisins elle a
permis une hausse de la fréquentation et
une amélioration des services alors la
libéralisation du rail est elle une
aubaine pour les utilisateurs tout
d'abord de quoi parle-t-on
l'union européenne voudrait à l'horizon
2020 que le trafic des passagers soit
ouvert la concurrence parfois sur une
même ligne différentes compagnies
pourraient donc rouler les prix
devraient baisser et les entreprises se
couperaient en quatre pour le client
bientôt un sandwich sncf trois étoiles
mais des molles le fret le transport de
marchandises a déjà été libéralisé et ce
ne fut pas une grande réussite
le fret s'effrite et depuis dix ans les
volumes transportés ont même diminué
pour ce qui est du transport voyageurs
15 pays ont déjà sauté le pas mais dans
des proportions différentes
alors comment ça se passe chez nos
voisins l'italie le premier pays à
s'être lancée dans la concurrence pas
sur des lignes régionales mais sur
quelques lignes à grande vitesse
il y a deux opérateurs en plus que
trenitalia et c'est une réussite
le prix du billet et jusqu'à 40% moins
chère et la fréquentation est en route
au royaume uni le chemin de fer et
l'attrait privatiser 25 compagnies se
partagent le gâteau
et ce n'est pas piece of cake les tarifs
ont explosé la sécurité a souffert et le
mécontentement gronde
certains parlent même de renationaliser
mais par contre la fréquentation a bible
en allemagne environ un quart du réseau
et privés principalement sur les lignes
régionales
la deutsche bahn qui a redressé ses
comptes garde les grandes lignes le
contrôle de voix et les gares von der
bach la fréquentation a bondi et la
satisfaction est plutôt au rendez vous
le modèle proposé par la france suivrait
l'aiguillage du modèle allemand plus
régulé la sncf garderai de grandes
prérogatives
donc quand on parle de fréquentation et
de services ce que dit edouard philippe
est plausible
alors voilà wunderbach c'est plausible
séville et qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
cette libéralisation du rail
sam aspire finalement deux remarques
dans le petit temps qui nous reste
d'abord il faut être attentif à
l'ensemble du réseau et à l'ensemble des
usagers concernés en france on a
manifestement eu un intérêt particulier
aux grands lignes tgv
mais il faut être effectivement attentif
à ce qui permet aux autres hommes des
taux de relier entre eux les trains du
quotidien
il n'y a pas d'alternative et la
deuxième chose qui est plus politique
c'est de considérer que quand un
gouvernement on veut passer
exclusivement par des ordonnances cder
en contournant la représentation
nationale
je trouve que c'est un peu gênant et ça
n'est pas forcément une très très très
très bon signe qui est donné aux claude
rolin l'ancien syndicaliste que vous
êtes
qu'est ce que ça lui inspire cette
privatisation cette libéralisation
parlant du rail en france en trente
secondes vous raconter une petite
histoire rapide tard que la semaine
dernière j'allais à paris pour un débat
sur le dialogue social et social
européen et je suis sûr la gare à sedan
dans les ardennes france
16 on annonce le tgv et puis cinq
minutes plus tard le chef de guerre
vient nous trouvons on était 4 5 très
tôt le matin en disant non il est
supprimé
je discute avec ce chef de guerre et
jeudi laisse arrive souvent ubiteam dit
monsieur ça arrive souvent
vous savez je crois que cette guerre
elle va bientôt être supprimée parce
qu'il n'y a plus assez de monde et puis
m'explique comment une vie dans son
village où l'entreprise a fermé et où la
vie en commun dans le village devient de
plus en plus compliqué et quand je
regarde la carte parce que je vois où il
habite
quand je vois la carte des résultats des
élections politiques et je vois en même
temps où l'extrême droite est en grande
montée c'est une question donc plus
large de services publics pour moi le
service est un événement qui structurent
nos territoires et donc est un élément
essentiel à la démocratie à la
construction du vivre ensemble non mais
écoutez ce sera le mot de la fin merci
en tout cas d'avoir participé à cette
émission rendez vous l'année prochaine
pour discuter parité et égaliser
salariale malheureusement nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine plutôt
vous retrouver à m tazir depuis
bruxelles très belle semaine à tous ciao
[Musique]